in this video we'll talk about telomere
replication so telome is present at the
ends of the chromosome and it's a
specialized structure found in the
eukariotic
chromosomes replicating the DNA at the
telome region is quite challenging in a
moment we would learn why it is so
challenging and how this challenge is
overcomed by a eukaryotic
cell so this is the end of the
chromosome and during the normal round
of DNA replication the enzyme that copy
the DNA could not copy the extreme end
of the
chromosome so let us try to delve into
details and understand this process so
here you can see the leading and the
lagging strand synthesis eventually the
synthesis is now reaching the end of the
DNA the end of the chromosome so the
leading strand is synthesized properly
in 5 Prime to 3 Prime Direction and
lagging strand is
basically synthesized in a discontinuous
man manner like a stitching back
mechanism so first you have to have a
RNA primer marked here in yellow and
then that primer has to be extended into
a five Prime to three prime
Direction now let's say there is the
extreme three prime hydroxy
end and eventually imagine AE
is uh attached at the extreme end so
obviously there would be a synthesis of
the DNA in the 5 Prime to 3 Prime
Direction but here is the
problem you can see the primers which
are attached which are marked here in
yellow would be removed eventually and
replaced by the DNA strands now
obviously these
primers that are present in the extreme
end
cannot get replaced because the problem
is while this primary replacement
happens a three prime o is required to
extend but where would be the fre three
prime o in the extreme end that is why
the end of the chromosome doesn't have
the leverage to replicate its end so he
this is known
as the end replication
problem now how this end replication
problem is solved with the help of tumas
teleras is an enzyme which has protein
subunits and RNA component so here is
the RNA component which plays a crucial
role in telome replication in a moment
it will be clear and here is a third
subunit which is basically telome is
reverse transcripted subunit so
basically telome is a enzyme of reverse
transcripts category it can form DNA
strands and basically it doesn't need an
external template so the template that
it uses is basically endogenous you can
see the RNA components Ser as the
template and it has an independent po
polymerous activity so here is the end
of the chromosome here you can see the
blue strand is the lagging strand and it
has to be extended otherwise there would
be problem
so the teleras sit in the end of the
Strand and there is a specific sequence
in the teleras in the RNA which is
conserved across UK carots and this
sequence is generally this one a a u Tri
C A A U and it binds to the end of the
DNA and then it starts synthesizing and
extending the
end one once this is done the teleras
would disengage and start this process
again so the extension would happen so
there would be repetitive addition in
the end of these chromosome so after few
Cycles there would be a overhang which
is
created eventually the teleras would be
disengaging and there are other
polymerase which would basically be
engaging there such as tnol Alpha and
then the other strand would be
synthesized so this is how the overall
telome shortening problem is
solved now question is how T length is
regulated at this point we have to
understand how teleras know how much to
extend the Tome it doesn't do it too
short it doesn't do it too long so how
this process is regulated latest
research from East suggests that there
are several telome binding protein which
which can regulate the teleras activity
such proteins are rap 1 riff one and
riff 2 they form a complex together and
can potentially inhibit the telas
activity now imagine two scenarios in
one scenario the telome length is quite
short in the right hand scenario the
telome length is quite long so this
particular protein bind to the double
stranded DNA so when the Tome length is
too
long there are too many enzyme complexes
that bind there and if there are so many
telome binding protein it would inhibit
or pose a strong inhibition on the
teleras so it would block the Tas
activity so here is the short length it
would pose a less tar binding protein
and less Tome binding would have less
inhibition so elongation of the telome
region would happen but imagine a
situation when there are the Tome length
is long then there would be more telar
binding proteins binding to that length
then there would be very strong
inhibition so elongation would be
prevented this is how a fine tuning
between the length of the telome is
maintained in the eukariotic
scenario now the end of the telome has
slight overhang at the three prime end
now the problem is this kind of overhang
can be treated as potential DNA Break by
the DNA repair Machinery in the cell now
this is something the cell doesn't want
so how this problem is
overcomed so the solution of the problem
is pretty simple fold it such that the
Machinery cannot recognize it so the
folding happens gradually and
sequentially in a stepwise fashion so
you can see first a looping mechanism
tucks the uh overhang inside and there
there is a strand inves process which
forms a loop like structure known as
tloop now this t- Loop act as a
protective cap for the end of the linear
chromosome and it prevents the telomeric
DNA overhang to be recognized by the
double Str DNA brick machinery and that
is how the telier is protected from a
any kind of
exonucleases onse uh activity now the
problem with telomere is telomere
shortening happens with each subsequent
cell division telomers naturally shorten
with each cell division due to the end
replication problem even if there is a
regulatory mechanism which ensures
telial length should be regulated but
still there is a shortening of the
telome now the problem is people think
that these Progressive shortening of the
telier is one of the key reason why
cells undergo a process known as
replicative cense the replicative cence
is a cellular State a situation where
cells fail to replicate their DNA
the growth and the division capability
is totally abrogated cell has reached a
sense uh stage and this is thought to be
the key driver for cellular
aging now the question is if this
particular Tome shortening can be
reversed then one might find the youth
Fountain but the problem lies there as
well it turns out there are cells which
can prevent any kind of Tome shortening
and can sort of have a fixed length of
the Tome telome and these cells are none
other than the cancer cells most of the
cancer cells have the ability to divide
rapidly and uncontrollably so obviously
if they divide so many times one would
expect the telome length to be very
short progressively in division but it
turns out that cancer cell has fairly
constant length of the telome now the
big question is how how cancer cells can
actually uh make maintain their length
over so many cell divisions so one side
Tome shortening is associated with aging
another side keeping the Tome length
cons consistent is associated with
cancer so how the Tome length is
regulated and Tome replication would
take place is a mystery still nowadays
and it's important to understand this
concept to have a better Outlook into
these uh scenarios so I hope this video
was useful if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe you can follow
our Instagram page you can follow our
all social media links provided in the
description you can uh support our
Channel using super thanks you can pay
via PTM PayPal or UPI see you in the
next
video